we have to remember the fact that we
have a proven history now that these
programs are not effective in the United
States we're a little bit ahead of the
game because we had we have had the
Boston Marathon bombings for example
where the United States government knew
who these individuals were in advance of
the attack they were already identified
known to the intelligence services but
despite the fact they were watching
everybody in the country they didn't
afford the attack and the question is
why the answer there is because when you
have individuals like me were ultimately
responsible for this going into a desk
every morning and trying to search
through the world's communications from
the previous day previously the previous
month you realized very quickly that it
would collect everything we understand
nothing